there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock
here we are back once again look at you
like looking at your drink level already
sure is mixed is that fruit pulp coming
down as you can see from the drink level
we've already been recording we did a
couple of movie reviews I'm warmed up
already oh yeah so this is episode 154
now I had initially planned a different
topic for this week which I'm actually
gonna FOB often next week but as I've
been working on my book faceless villain
3 which is only two chapters from being
done so like I said I'm I'm on track it
should be done by the end of August just
like I said hopefully yeah so it'll be
out very soon while I was researching
that the other day one of the cases that
I was writing about when I was writing
the chapter about 1997 I started reading
about it and I'm like oh man I remember
this case cuz I saw it like a long time
ago on unsolved mysteries and I remember
thinking it was really weird back at the
time so then when I started like
researching it and writing about it and
stuff like that I was like oh man we
have to do a show about this is one of
the weirdest disappearance and murder
cases and pretty much ever like that
I've ever heard of yeah she's been
saving it she hadn't told me you think
about just like the details about her
just so strange and it's just like I
don't I don't know that this kind of
like reminded me it's right up there
with that remember when we did that show
on like about Roland Owen like the guy
that was staying at the hotel room and
then like he turned up dead like after
all the foam being off the hook you know
they're kind of weird [ __ ] you know and
he was dead in there even though nobody
saw anybody go in the room and stuff
this is kind of a little bit like that
um not quite so much but it's just
I can't really think of any specific
reason why this would have happened the
way it happened but apparently it did
happen like that
what are you gonna call this case um I
just called it murder of Judy Smith
because that was the woman's name all
right
and it happened in 1997 and we will get
into it like I said one when I started
researching the case legit spent eight
straight hours reading everything I cook
yeah yeah yeah that's where I came
across a sound like a teaser yeah that's
where I came across it and like I said
once I started reading about it I was
like oh ever hearing about this on on
top mysteries like years and years and
years ago so that's what we're gonna be
talking about episode 154 today so
hopefully you guys will enjoy it and
find it as fascinating as I found it um
so let's see we'll do a couple of
shoutouts firstly our friends of the
show Sophie who art who also stayed with
us she sent us a big-ass box of candy
yeah for Mackinac Island economic in
Michigan which I also did a show about
if you remember correctly all real
saltwater taffy and turn it up did we
eat all the fudge on Ivy uh I think it's
a little bit of fuzz left okay yeah I
just good push that peanut butter buzz
oh my god they were all good it was
three different flavors yeah difference
between a saltwater taffy you know this
but it's amazing because like
store-bought saltwater taffy is
artificially flavored I'm it's good uh
you know I eat it I eat the [ __ ] out of
it but it's kind like starbursts you can
just sit there and just eat a ball all
day yeah no not a handmade taffy can't
do that it's got natural flavors and
just the way it is after you eat about
ten pieces of it you're satisfied yeah
it's kind of like you can't eat a whole
bunch of fudge yeah I mean try to eat
speak for yourself
I mean you have to come back take a
second run at
yeah it's good yeah it's like I'm
candies rich yeah and like that taffy
that we got from there it's like I mean
you know I'm not like hugely into like
fruity type candies and stuff like that
but that taffy is almost like it's so
creamy it's like not even like a fruity
candy and like that maple taffy is out
of this world
yeah and the chocolate tip the chocolate
is kind of like tootsie rolls yeah it
has it has like that soft creamy kind of
throat kind of creamy kind of texture to
it it's really really nice I think I
haven't tried like all of the flavors
but I think I like that maple in the
best way you blocking me blocking
Mackenzie all right I'm doing a karate
block like I said it started really
early yeah um and I would also like to
thank our newest patron whose name is
Holly she just came on and a couple of
days so thank you very much and welcome
to our patreon page and we really
appreciate all of you guys
contributions patrons get early access
they do I put everything up a day before
and if you're $20 or more we send you a
free shirt at 1/4 yeah the next one made
by me and I made this one - yeah I'm
gonna plug obscure undead yeah friends
of ours who are our own DJs yes doing
goth music reviews DJ Mouse and one
other DJ yeah but they're at a tank
based out of Tampa Mouse to be here
Friday to pick up the rest of our shirts
yeah cuz we made her a bunch of those
shirts and she's gonna come over Friday
and pick some up she's playing a gig
here isn't she she's DJing here in
Orlando so yeah all right so uh I think
that's probably all the shoutouts right
cuz I said thanks oh yeah cuz I said the
book will be done you know in a couple
of months and or at least by the end of
next month so you ready to do this case
I'm ready
okay okay I'm interested to hear like
what your theories are I don't know
anything about about this so just I'm
gonna lay out the story I have a lot of
details about this so wait don't brush
me through the [ __ ] so I'm gonna set the
scene no rush you set the scene all
right so this happened it started out in
Boston now the victim of this crime was
a fifty year old woman named Judy Smith
she was a homecare nurse very successful
at her job actually um as far as I could
determine she was so loved at some of
her jobs that you know because homecare
nurse you know you you stay in the house
with the family and like taking care of
people like long-term care and stuff
like that I mean she one of the families
that she worked for invited her to like
Thailand with them like two with the fit
with the family so she was like she got
close enough to these families that she
was like very close to them so I'm just
saying she was he seemed like a very
nice woman she was very good at her job
so she lived in a part it looked kind of
a ritzy area of Boston with her husband
Jeffrey now he was her third husband he
was a corporate lawyer I believe he was
a lawyer some kind of belief it was a
corporate lawyer now Judy had two kids
from I think her first marriage they
were grown and Jeffrey also had I
believe a daughter who was older teenage
or early 20s from his first marriage now
they had actually met ten years before
in 1987 I guess because Judy had been
hired to take care of Jeffrey's dad
after his dad had like a he had the like
a tumor in his neck and he had to have
it removed you know he had like cancer
and so he was like bedridden for a long
time so she was the home the home health
care nurse and I guess you know while
she was taking care of the dad like her
and Jeffrey fell in love and so they
dated for like a really long time lived
together for a few years and they had
just got married in September of 1996
now only a few months later they decide
they're gonna take like kind of a big
trip together
it's April 9th 1997 now they're both
going to Logan International Airport in
Boston they're gonna go to Philadelphia
Jeffery is involved and might have been
like one of the sort of like organizers
of it there's like a big 3-day like
pharmaceutical conference or something
like that there it sounds like super
boring but whatever so he like
represented this big pharmaceutical
company so he was gonna go and he was
like supposed to like you know mediate
some of the panels and they had all
these sessions and you know kids
corporate conference kind of [ __ ] so
he's gonna be there for three days now
judy has never been to Philadelphia
before and you know they have money so
she's like hey well you know I'll buy a
ticket and I'll tag along with you and
I'll do some sightseeing while you're
you know doing your conference [ __ ] cuz
I'm not gonna do that
so she went you know she wants to go
around the city and see everything so
and then they said well you know after
the the conference was only three days I
think it started what we was like
Wednesday Thursday Friday or something
and then they said oh we'll just pop
over to New Jersey after because it's
not very far they had some friends there
and they were gonna stay with their
friends over the weekend so they had
this whole like big trip planned itchin
so they get to the airport and Judy
discovers that she has forgotten her
driver's license now it's it's
interesting like nowadays
obviously you can't go anywhere without
your [ __ ] driver's license especially
on a plane um in 1997 it actually
happened that it had only been about
eighteen months since they had made it
like that you had to show an ID to get
on the plane so I guess like even into
the 90s I didn't even remember this even
into the like mid nineties you could
still conceivably get an airplane
without showing anyone your ID which is
kind of scary yeah but I guess you could
yeah like what you bought a ticket and
you obviously didn't like it anyone ever
then take it so next time you take guns
on the airplane well use be able to
smoke on airplanes you'll be able do all
kind of crazy
you didn't have it in the overhead
storage compartment but you could put
your guns in the baggage and they put it
up a bit underneath though I don't need
the play yes II wouldn't get to it would
get ya
while the plane was going but yeah you
couldn't do that now I don't think no
well transport I don't think you can
transport a firearm in there anymore um
you might be able to but it might dumb
sure there's like a whole bunch of
procedure yet procedures about it cuz I
mean I think you can pretty much
transport anything as long as you like
do the protocols correctly and that's
other kind of [ __ ] hope though but she
um yes so she didn't have her ID and she
didn't think they were gonna let her on
the plane so she's like well [ __ ] I'm
gonna have to go all the way back home
and get you know and get it we're gonna
miss the flight
now Jeffrey had to he had to be in
Philadelphia that afternoon because he
was supposed to be on some panels or he
had some sessions or some [ __ ] at the
conference that he had to do so they
were kind of like okay well Jeffrey is
just gonna go ahead to Philadelphia and
then Judy was gonna go home pick up her
Heidi and then she was gonna come back
to the airport and try to get a later
flight and then they were gonna meet up
because they already had hotel
reservations and all that those the kind
of stuff so they thought that it that
would all work out it was the Doubletree
Hotel in Center City Philadelphia so
that seemed to have gone as they planned
and I say seemed which will become clear
later uh-huh
she goes home and gets her ID comes back
she catches a 7:30 flight to
Philadelphia and supposedly arrives in
Philadelphia at around 10:00 p.m. now
apparently she had even brought Jeffrey
some flowers I guess to say hey I'm
sorry I [ __ ] up and I you know we were
supposed to come here together blah blah
blah like I made a mistake and so she
felt really bad about it so then they
just apparently went to bed I don't know
cuz you know there was I went on a bunch
of like web forums about this room it
was like arguing about these little
details about the case and everything
but um I'm not sure I'm assuming that
her luggage just went ahead to
Philadelphia ahead of her you know I
mean because I'm imagining they already
had it on the plane if he went and he
just took her luggage with him and she
just came back with a carry-on I'm
assuming
I don't know if that's really what
happened or not so the next morning
Jeffery gets up a long time before Judy
did he goes down and eats breakfast cuz
you know hotels they give you that free
breakfast bar and all that other kind of
stuff which is nothing you don't miss
out on that ship and of course you know
it's like that's pretty much the only
time I'll get up early it's a free eight
[ __ ] man some of it some of these man
cells
yeah they got all kind of good [ __ ] now
they had grits they got a like a [ __ ]
waffle bar they got [ __ ] creeps and
pancakes and all kind of [ __ ] you got it
four people on their door love grits are
Chris yeah where did that come it comes
off the grit tree yeah son of the grits
summer grits are in season you guys
never had grits you know we're
southerners we [ __ ] love grits are
very divisive I feel you gotta know what
to do with grits grits are made out of
hominy-hominy-hominy you feed cattle
yeah put that into a bucket a whole
bunch of water or a big big 50 gallon
oil drop full of water throw lye lye and
it starts to expand and be like popcorn
yeah that's called hominy few people
don't know then you drain that you take
that out and you kind of beat it into a
kind of like a polenta yeah you say yeah
that is a good way of putting it like a
polenta man so good but then you didn't
you can uh you can dry it too you know
you can redraw it and then you know so
when you get grits they're not wet
they're not ready they're that looks
like cornmeal yeah exactly what it looks
like in rehydrated it's good it's gonna
put meat and cheese yes but Isis got put
stuff in it I mean they're not bad but
they don't really taste like no taste
like thanks right yeah I mean you know
my grandmother she would put sugar in
hers yeah it's essentially I was gonna
say it's like oatmeal but it's not quite
it's more like cream of wheat yeah it's
like a similar you know I mean if you've
had cream of wheat I like about putting
sugar in it that's what it's a corn
that's it yeah that's the same way black
people eat it in in Mississippi with
sugar yeah that's where she got that
idea yeah yeah
she always ate it with sugar you're
right I like you too a salt and pepper
butter
cheese yeah and then like break up a
bunch of little bacon throw make bacon
bits fresh bacon bits in it usually I'd
make it yeah we put hard-boiled eggs in
my chops up hard-boiled eggs everything
just but really I mean if you can have
it plain yeah like just salt pepper and
like a [ __ ] ton of butter yeah really
good you got a lot of people like in
Australia England Oh need them plane now
anybody yeah we got and here's another
thing is that you can't store them you
got to eat them all because as soon as
you put them less there go to one suit
yet soon as there soon as soon as they
get cold they just set up my concrete
yes every block can't really and
reactivate them a lot like it what no
you can't have leftovers no cuz
sometimes like every now and then will
want some and he'll make like a big pot
of grits and then he'll put like cheese
and eggs and like bacon bits and stuff
like that in it and thank you so much
but you have to eat it all or you're
gonna have to read water or I don't even
think that's gonna work I've gotten it
back to where it was where it was kind
of like I mean it's still kind of lumpy
but it still kind of low it's not as if
you're in England or in Australia and
you want Europe somewhere you know you
want to try some real [ __ ] hockey
fluid man you order some grits and learn
how to make it it's good
awesome shrimp and grits the shrimp is
like a big thing here - like a Cajun
version like Cajun yeah that's really
good because it's also good crawfish
tails it is yeah but you
thanks forever to get down meat out of
it but like you said it's like it's not
you know people pick on southerners was
like Oh grits ooh they're so gross and
everything but like you said I mean it's
not really that different from cream of
wheat or polenta or certainly it's
pretty much the same thing as that yes
just corn it's just a yeah it's just our
version of it and honestly Mike you know
what my grandmother would even eat white
hominy just ran out of the can yeah how
many's good if you know what to do with
it - you know of course she'd also eat
calves brains and scrambled oh yeah I'm
like yeah I'm not
you know I'll eat most things but I kind
of draw the line at brain holding little
grids with hard-boiled eggs yeah it gets
real good in the bowl with it yeah it
was boom yeah Shanta cheese salt pepper
huge bags of good real bacon bits hmm it
is good it's like it's really all you
need to eat all day though because it's
like that's really good it's very very
filling make you fat it's very filling
make you [ __ ] fat
I even like those instant ones man yeah
that's not bad yeah I'll even eat those
damn just through our like half a stick
of butter and then want to go real
old-school southern you make red-eye
gravy with that yeah hambone
yeah yeah hambone you can get a hambone
a winn-dixie yeah need a hand bone for
that least she used to be able to I mean
I can all right
so every time we like Goa's cuz all i
said all i said was he went down back to
eat the free breakfast in there yeah
yeah we really need to do like a food
yeah because it seems like every time we
mention anything to do with food it's
like we go well because he cooks and
like it yeah so he's got like a lot of
good recipes yeah so okay so he goes
down takes advantage of the free
breakfast I don't know I'm assuming you
probably ate a lot cuz he's kind of a
big fat dude but um yeah so he goes down
there he comes back to the room at about
9:00 in the morning and his wife
according to him was awake and was in
the shower and he's like oh breakfast
was really good you should go down there
and get some and she's like oh I'm gonna
go down like I am I'm all wet naked ha
ha ha you know so they were like joking
about it so then he leaves the room now
here's where stuff starts getting weird
so okay so he leaves the room and starts
going and doing his [ __ ] at the
conference now what Judy had planned to
do or at least what she told him she had
planned to do was that she was gonna go
sightseeing around the city she's like I
want to see the Liberty Bell
specifically I want to see Independence
Hall
now if you've ever been to Philadelphia
I've only been one time and that was a
very long time ago but they actually
have a bus service called the flash pH F
no pH la Sh that's a journey spell yeah
um and it goes around to like all the
tourists you know you just get on it
it's one like one of those tourist buses
where you can get on it at any point
it'll take you I don't like all the
tourist [ __ ] in the city so they had one
of those so she was apparently gonna do
that so the couple says all right well
I'm gonna do it go do my thing you go do
your thing and we'll meet back here
between like 5:00 and 5:30 because
apparently like the conference the
pharmaceutical conference was having
like a big cocktail hour a big cocktail
party at 6 p.m. and he was supposed to
go to it and she was gonna go with him
so they were gonna come back to the room
and change and you know go to the party
so Jeffery goes and does his [ __ ] and he
comes back to the room at about 5:30
that afternoon and notices that Judy is
not there now this didn't alarm him at
first he was probably like oh you know
maybe she just lost track of time out
sightseeing or whatever he's like or
perhaps she forgot what our plan was she
came back to the room earlier she
changed and went down to the cocktail
party already because it was in you know
just one of the conference rooms in the
same hotel so he says well I'll just go
get changed and I'll go down to the
party and see if I can find her so he
goes down there to the party and he
doesn't see her and he's asking around
because some of his colleagues were
there and they knew her you know or at
least knew what she looked like
they're like yeah man we haven't seen
her you know she hasn't been here so he
kept going back and forth like from the
room to the party and then she wasn't
there so finally he's like ok
he thinks something bad has happened so
he goes out on the street and he gets a
cab and he tells the cab to follow the
route that the flash bus would have
taken like you know just follow it very
slowly and he's like I'm just gonna like
look out the window and look for cuz
maybe she's still like wandering around
the streets and where something like
that so they did that and they also did
not see any sign of her he also called
their kids you know she had two kids and
they were grown up but you know and he
had one kid so he called them he said
you know call our house you know let's
see if there's any messages on our
answering machines like maybe she called
the house and said something like she
was going someplace you know none of the
kids had heard from her there were no
messages in the phone nothing like that
so about midnight he's like okay well
I'm getting a report her missing because
this is not like her so he goes to the
police station and he says I want to
report my wife missing and the police
were kind of like nah because it hadn't
been 24 hours you know how they do like
in some cities there's like well if
they're a grown up person if it has been
24 hours you can't file a
missing-persons report because they
figure well the person just wandered off
of their own volition and according to
Jeffrey Smith he's like they were kind
of pretty um
dismissive about his concerns they were
just kind of like oh you know how fifty
year old women do like they have these
you know midlife crises or something and
just decided to like wander off and not
tell anyone they're coming so I guess
they didn't really think it was they
were like no big you know she'll
probably be back or whatever and he was
kind of upset about this because this
was apparently not something that his
wife would have done so he goes back to
the hotel like I said he's kind of a you
know high police lawyer and at this
conference it so happened that there
were two kind of colleagues of his one
of whom happened to be the mayor of
Philadelphia and another of whom
happened to be a member of the
Philadelphia House of Representatives so
he goes in there he's like you guys you
know I'm trying to like you know my
wife's missing and I'm trying to report
her missing and the police are just kind
of being like nah bro and they're kind
of like brushing me off about it so can
you guys like put in a word you know so
they apparently did now he waited a
couple of hours but then he went back to
the police station like early the next
morning even though it hadn't been 24
hours he's like oh they were much more
receptive so I guess like the mayor had
called and be like don't be such a dick
with the [ __ ] you know
yeah help it help the guy out so now
again this is where it gets weird so
this woman is like disappeared
so then they start interviewing you know
other people that were at the conference
people that worked at the hotel people
that like burgess wander around the
street that day or whatever you know
they're trying to find out like what the
timeline was like where this woman went
because apparently according to Geoffrey
Smith the last time that he had seen her
she was in the shower at about 9:00 a.m.
at the hotel room and she had said she
was gonna go out sightseeing and then
nothing ever came to light nobody's are
now so they asked some of the employees
at the doubletree hotel where they were
saying now according to one desk clerk
he said that Judy had come up to him
like in like the late morning of April
10th which I'm assuming was like 10 or
11 o'clock and said where is the best
place to catch the flash bus which you
know that was that job booth what she
was planning on doing um they one of the
drivers of the flash bus of one of the
routes also said yeah I think I saw her
like I picked her up at the intersection
of Front Street and South Street like
fairly early in the afternoon and then
he said later in the day I dropped her
off near the hotel like we neared the
Doubletree another employee or another
person that was attending the same
conference as Geoffrey said that he
thought he saw her in the lobby on that
day although he said I can't be quite
sure because I don't really know her
that well it he's like when I kind of
saw her from far away but I'm pretty
sure it was her so some people did seem
to see her in the hotel because like I
said there's later on like as the
investigation went on there was some
speculation that maybe she had never
even come to Philadelphia and had
disappeared like earlier and then her
husband was like trying to cover it up
or something like that so apparently
there were some people that saw her in
Philadelphia some people on the street
also said that they had seen a woman
that looked like her going into the
Philadelphia Greyhound bus terminal and
then coming back out a few minutes later
now they didn't think there was a lot of
significance to that they said maybe she
just went in there to use the bathroom
or something like that also they said it
was interesting because
where the Greyhound bus terminal was
they said it was real close to
Philadelphia's Chinatown and they said
that sounds like some where she would be
because Judy Smith was like super into
like Thai food and Chinese food and
every time she traveled to a new city
she always like looked for Chinese
restaurants and Thai restaurants so that
seemed like somewhere she would be
although they did interview like pretty
much all the people who were like worked
in the restaurants and stuff like that
and they said that they had not seen her
whether that's the case or not I don't
know now
there were also some sightings of her
that were decidedly weirder although
they're not quite sure if these were
actually her or not
now there were staff members at this
other hotel called the Society Hill
Hotel that wasn't that far away and they
said that they're like yeah this woman
that looked like Judy Smith stayed here
from the 13th to the 15th and she had
checked in under a different name
HK rich Collins and they said we
remembered this woman specifically
because she was acting like a lunatic
they said she was speaking in tongues
she was masturbating in front of a
window damn
and she said that [ __ ] on video but yeah
so and she apparently told the desk
clerk that well I'm gonna extend my stay
but I'm waiting for somebody that she
called the Emperor to wire me more money
yeah Tromp so I don't know what that was
all that amber ara that's ridiculous
yeah so this sounds like a damn brain
hemorrhage
well yeah that's what I mean if these
are her that's then that might be the
case but this is gonna get weirder
before kids so I'm not really sure what
to think you know yeah so there were
some other sightings of a woman who
looked a lot like her and she also she
was walking around the intersection of
Lucas Street and Broad Street and she
appeared disoriented this was around 3
p.m. on the afternoon of April 10th when
Judy Smith would have been walking
around sightseeing now she's 50 right
yeah um other no I'm asking that why
well the audience doesn't know this but
man we knew a girl at the club who was
not even maybe 30 you look at her you
know she's just real tall long blond
hair good-looking girl seemed totally
normal
then we just she's dead brain brain
tumor yep
and there was a night and she was
playing ninety nine no warning she had
been sickly but I don't know if it was
specifically that yeah I don't think
they knew that she had a brain tumor do
they know not at that age they wouldn't
check for anything like that no if
that's like a watch and like I said I
think I mentioned this maybe on one of
our other shoes but I had an uncle yeah
that died of a brain tumor when he was
32 yeah it does happen it's very rare
and then there was that other guy that
guy who Lizzie no goth dude that was ex
DJ he was younger than me he was walking
around normal and then just a few weeks
later I said men and [ __ ] get
skinny and remember that member and then
yeah dead yep
dead Harry yeah it didn't happen
same thing brain tumor yeah yeah you
were old enough to where we start
knowing people who they're dying that
should've [ __ ] shake your foundations
well into rusty and two of my friends
this year got can't got cancer and
they're young yeah well one is wanted to
be 152 but the other one is area 30
something yeah she's like a local golf
club hottie girl who is she's only 33
damson up on you look at her she's got
stomach kids yeah beautiful
you know you she's up there dancing you
know it skimpy outfits you know she's
just like a go-go dancer and the next
thing you know you find out she's just
eaten up with cancer yep yeah it's kind
of like that Alex Jones stuff about
their putting stuff in the water and
they're trying to kill us with cellphone
radiation makes you wonder ran it makes
you
I mean people die
they do well yeah and like I said one of
those statistics it's unusual for
someone that young and like I said I
mean yeah it's weird that somebody we
know is that young and it's weird that
my uncle did that but in general most
people that I've cast I had a theory I'd
already told Jenny we were a boot drive
at one time I had this theory in the
middle in the lower middle class they
have these old houses that they live in
they were built a lot of them were built
in the 50s 60s 70s they weren't really
built for central air and a lot of them
are just running window units and it
makes me wonder if lack of proper
ventilation is somehow killing a lot of
people early here because you never know
in this heat and this humidity of what
could build up inside of a house they
like little mold spores
well yeah kill you first yeah because
you know we you go into one of those
houses and you know I always always the
first thing that always second I noticed
was like the smell of mold yeah in all
of those old houses and it doesn't
necessary no I'm not saying you know
they're dirty or anything you know those
people are dirty it's because they just
weren't built with modern central air
yeah man we live in Florida and like
everything is swampy and [ __ ] a good
time
this is Dagobah okay yeah x-wings right
out back okay exhaling back seriously I
mean we're in an air-conditioned house
if I get out of the shower and
immediately start sweating yeah it's you
can't escape it got a badass
air-conditioner and in the in the heat
of the in the heat of the summer day in
the hottest parts of the summer you're
not gonna get it below 74 yeah and in
here you can have that air conditioner
your answer will blow up you can have
that Central Terminal wide up wide open
and you're not gonna get it below 74
well keep it set on 71 all year round
and it still doesn't it just it doesn't
matter she Lisa like the the old air
conditioned that I used to have like in
the
where my family grew up it would break
every year because it just couldn't
catch yeah make it so hard just to try
to keep the house cool yeah and I have a
four window units and another one that
can go indoors that can exhaust out they
work like [ __ ] they don't know I have
four of those in the garage in case we
lose air conditioning yeah because we
had that happen a couple if you lose
power you lose air contain and I got
generators out there to [ __ ] to power
the houses last couple of years we had
to hurry storms yeah I got a nice Honda
generator power went out nice new Honda
generator and if you lose power in a
house in a modern house like this and
you know I have air conditioning in four
hours
it smells like a [ __ ] swamp in here
yeah because of the humidity you
remember bacteria just [ __ ] goes yeah
crazy years ago it might have been two
or three years ago when we had those
hurricanes and the power was out for
several days yeah and we didn't have the
generator then and remember we were
filling the tub with ice and sleeping
and oh yeah yeah that first storm we
went through yeah yeah and then I got
that other generator and that generator
ran like [ __ ] and I had Revenge Lee I
was nursing that generator yeah a storm
for about four days I finally got my
hands on one of the good [ __ ] Honda
generators that [ __ ] about $4,000
yeah I could power this out in the whole
house yeah two refrigerators they just
didn't want to go through that don't
it's not worth it here there's not to
have AC in a modern houses like death
well embassies are high enough well and
plus like so much like cuz we shop at
Sam's like once a month so if the power
goes out we we lose like five hundred
dollars worth of food and they have to
keep you have to keep all the
refrigerator's going yeah and we except
we have to and all those window units
yeah and you got to put window units in
this Houston and it won't get cold
really just that it won't get it'll just
like keep you from happy right yeah for
window units are probably keep this
place at about 85 you know yeah they're
it's like there are some things that I
like about Florida but that's one thing
and I was born here
think I've been used to it you never get
used to it I've always hated they I hate
hot weather out of my summer I stay
indoors most summer yeah yeah it's like
I still do my walks and stuff but I try
to do them like early in the morning
like before it gets too bad yeah and you
know we'd have friends come from [ __ ]
Europe you know in England and stuff in
it for some reason they love the heat
they love it because they're not used to
it they're [ __ ] weird we had this
girl come visited us and she was talking
wearing whole [ __ ] dresses and
jackets and it was in them dead lifts
dead the [ __ ] stuff like July or
something she's all dressed up like she
was downtown London or some [ __ ] like
that look you were gonna pass out yeah
oh it's not bad it keeps the heat out no
but I guess because they don't live in
it yeah it's just like a couple of days
of an excursion it's kind of like I
guess if you're used to like shitty cold
rainy weather yes I go to the sauna like
oh this is but you don't want to live in
the sauna but we do yet eventually wears
you out yeah usually it just makes you
tired you didn't like do anything it
just makes you tired you have to go
outside really it's just it makes you
time so much more energetic like in them
and it doesn't even really get that cold
here in the wintertime like I'm always
hoping that it'll get almost like
hibernate during the summer pretty much
stay in the house and just do warehouse
work yeah yeah make an excuse not to go
outside yeah it's like we really have to
go there she stuck the Algeciras it's
like that damn movie swedish apocalypse
movie where they can't go outside and
they got all the damn glasses on
radiation QE yeah pretty much yeah
they're like that that's like our life
every day at least during the summer
it's not bad in the winter it's actually
pretty nice it's a little too warm for
my day still but yeah alright so as I
said there were some sightings of this
of a woman that looked like Judy Smith
walking around like in the kind of
touristy areas looking as though she was
disoriented
this apparently the same woman was seen
also appearing disoriented walking
around Penn's Landing and another gun
there was a homeless guy in the area and
when the cops showed him a picture of
Judy he said yeah that woman slept on a
bench next to me on April 14th like
overnight
April 14th hmm now something that
complicates the situation though is that
there was a fairly well-known homeless
woman who lived in Philadelphia at the
time like on the streets and she looked
a lot like Judy Smith like she was about
the same age like she was kind of
heavyset like you might never get
herring out there yeah and she was
blonde she had like the similar similar
kind of haircut yeah um and from what
I've read she looked so much like Judy
Smith that like when her son came to
Philadelphia like to help the you know
the dad like in the search and
everything like that he actually thought
he saw his mom like across the street
like he was looking at a window but it
was actually this homeless woman so so
like I said she did look a lot like him
it should be noted though that even
though there was this homeless woman
going around that supposedly looked so
much like Judy Smith that you know the
Sun couldn't tell the difference at
least from across the street
the homeless man that they asked the one
that said yeah Judy Smith's you know
slept on a bench next to me on August
14th she he said no I know that homeless
woman it wasn't her it was this other
woman that you showed me a picture of so
take that however you want to take it so
like I said I don't know how many of
these sightings were hurt and how many
were not her you know what I mean
because there was that whole
complicating issue of this kind of
look-alike just doppelganger that she
had marker on the street now over the
ensuing days there were also some other
sightings of her that were like farther
away so this one woman that worked at a
Macy's in Deptford New Jersey said yeah
Judy was in here shopping for dresses
and she's like and I talked to her she
didn't seem like distressed she didn't
seem like there was anything wrong with
she said that she was buying a dress for
her daughter and then kind of made a
joke about oh you know my daughter never
likes anything that I buy for her
now when the retail clerk said that to
the family like when the family found
out about this yeah that sounds like
something that Judy would do and that
sounds like something that she would say
now this woman also said and I'm not
sure like what the outcome of this was
but she's like this woman that it said
I'm buying a dress for my daughter so
she attempted to get a younger woman
presumably her daughter to leave the
store with her and I'm assuming that
because she said attempted that maybe
she was not successful like she tried to
get a girl to leave the store with her
and it didn't work out so maybe that yes
so that was pretty weird too now it
should be noted that I mean it sounds
like oh it's Deford New Jersey but I
mean Philadelphia and New Jersey you
know in Deptford New Jersey are not that
far apart and there's actually you can
get a bus from Philadelphia New Jersey
Transit bus route 400 which goes right
to Deptford New Jersey and you can get
there like in a pretty short amount of
time so they're like it's possible that
she might have just like caught a bus to
macy's in New Jersey for whatever reason
they did have friends in New Jersey but
I don't know if it was if that's where
the friends were so somebody else
spotted who they thought was Judy in
Easton Pennsylvania which is about 50
miles away from Philadelphia that was a
few days after the disappearance another
guy who was driving to work at about
6:00 a.m. a few days after her
disappearance also saw her he said she
appeared to be well dressed and she was
sitting in front of a gourmet grocery
store in Philadelphia at around 6:00
a.m. which she thought was very weird
because I guess the grocery store wasn't
open yet and she was like sitting on the
sidewalk in front of it hmm so I don't
know if that was her either but he said
it looked a lot like her oh let's talk
about food and grocery stores and
gourmet grocery stores make me wonder
what was on the menu in that place man
it was probably like a Whole Foods if
they had those back in the 90s
oh yeah they did like fancy
I mean we only just started getting them
down here like a few years ago but I
think they had them in other parts of
the country hungry you're always making
me hungry go ahead I see her so all
right so obviously they have no idea
where this woman is gone Jeffery Smith
the husband he spends a lot of his own
money like over the ensuing several
months he hired three separate private
investigators he made thousands and
thousands and thousands of fliers with
his wife's picture on there and faxed
them to pretty much every police station
and Hospital in America as far as I know
so you know so everyone got one now it
should be noted that because in 85 90
percent of cases where a woman
disappears usually it's something to do
with her husband her boyfriend or
whoever so police were looking askance
at Jeffery Smith even from the beginning
thinking that maybe he was involved like
I said there was even some speculation
that she hadn't even come to
Philadelphia at all and that like maybe
he had killed her beforehand and then
set this whole thing up like as an alibi
so there was a whole bunch of other kind
of [ __ ] about that too but you know they
didn't have enough there didn't really
seem to be any reason for him to do
anything like that and at this point
they had not found her now they didn't
find her until September 7th 1997 now
there was a father and son who were out
deer hunting out of season so naughty
naughty
yes poaching in and I don't know what
state was this they it was actually
North Carolina poaching in North
Carolina yeah they must be very tolerant
over there
you can't poach a Mississippi Louisiana
Alabama mutant just a serious [ __ ]
time yeah I don't know like if these
guys ended up doing any time for this
around it's like but you know they found
a body so I guess they figured yeah
come forward yeah yeah people living
outside the United States you can't just
go hunting in the United State well you
can if it's a varmint maybe they were
just hunting varmint were they hunting
deer deer they were hunting deer okay
only certain times of the year you can
do that you need a license he permission
yeah and the license is only good for
that year we had any kind of like this
is kind of like large named animals yeah
although it made it Pan's I think you
can buy licenses at last you can buy
them they'll cover several seasons but
oh and there's things called game
wardens so they're clear cops they have
more power than a cop they can go into
your house without a warrant and check
your freezer and see if you have gained
meat in there yeah they can do a whole
forensic exam to see if that came from a
deer try to figure out where that came
from and what did it feel like my
neighbor gave it to me I didn't I didn't
shoot any yeah yeah yeah so you know as
long as you follow the rules you can
pretty much do what you want but you
can't just do whatever you want well I
hope you God give those deer a rest
man you gotta give them a rest you don't
want to hunt them out you know you
you're cultivating them well yeah we
manage I know in pretty much every state
that I know of yeah at least where
hunting is a thing it's there's a lot of
misconceptions about it it's very much
kind of like a more humane version in
terms of the deer it's a more humane
version of say raising cattle raising
cattle they're raised in captivity the
deer are raised in the wild you get
permission to go out huntin ones and
just culling off the top yeah you know
you're looking for males that have
already reproduced and the females live
a long time
those are your baby machines well yeah
you know valuable yeah yeah they are
yeah so they can that baby and there are
so many and they're hunting deer and
they're hot deer in Florida there are so
many deer here it's not even funny
I say them all that she sees them all in
there they're almost a nuisance you can
hit them with your motorcycle your car's
you know it'll kill you if you hit him
on a motorcycle I almost like you my car
one yeah they almost need to start
hunting them down here to get rid of
them they're just too damn many of them
I saw one another morning I saw um I saw
a doe
a little fun yeah just hanging out in
somebody's yard when I was out for a
walk but we're just like walking down
the path man there's yeah try blow
Europeans mind I know because the
European specially over in England also
islands they've eaten every [ __ ]
thing over the centuries really no
animals there well no big animal no big
animals here there they're just [ __ ]
everywhere and we're hunting them
what we see bear in our neighborhood no
driveway you know Drive you know they
just seem dear enough whether it was a
deer with a broken leg
no that yard on our back porch I was
tempted to shoot it to put it out of its
misery
yes well that was my style I called I
called him and I didn't have permission
to do that yeah they just said just
they've been trying to catch it yeah and
they say it'll don't walk but it was it
was dangling I thought I got hit by a
car and they said I'll just let it die
it says man it's a and it was all [ __ ]
getting infected and riding and I said
man has a slow painful death and he says
yeah but that's that's just nature
looked at our sliding glass window I'm
like holy crap there's a deer that's
sitting right that it was right there it
was literally like two feet yeah from
our I was at window a pistol shot you
could have killed down to 25 I know a
380 yeah then she like she kind of got
spooked and like kind of hobbled off
like when we went out there to see what
was going on yeah yeah the United States
just [ __ ] you know
yeah people in New York in California
they never see an animal and they think
that [ __ ] all all the animals are
dying
no they're [ __ ] all here in Florida
they're [ __ ] everywhere deer bears
bear bear
tortoises awesome scene all right yeah
[ __ ] tons of squirrels with the squirrel
just a damn tree rat and you know if
Bobcat Bobcats snakes alligators yeah
and we're in the suburbs yeah so that
should tell you some yeah we're not like
in a city so you know it worse up we're
in a pretty built-up area and this
nature is doing fine nature is doing
very fine
yeah and you know I've seen things in
Mississippi they weren't opposed to be
there like coyote that's just be
something out west we see coyote
you know never I told you my coyote
stuff yeah a shot that coyote and it
lived and then my dad's friend killed it
seven years later
yeah and it still had that bad eye yeah
it didn't hit the eye I didn't know it
was a coyote I wouldn't have shot it
yeah I had orders to shoot that [ __ ] but
cuz he runned the deer off he's just a
damn dog there was stuff about animals
we really didn't know back then yeah you
know I mean because we don't have the
Internet
I didn't realize raccoons were as
friendly as they were raccoons are
awesome raccoons are very friendly and
it depends on where you are I guess all
they call them trash pandas and I had
yeah I have no idea that you could tame
Fox and coyote we thought that yeah we
thought those were undemanding uh wild
animals that could not be domesticated
same thing with like servals and
mountain lions you know we thought those
were vicious and there's no way to tame
them hell no then [ __ ] the sweethearts
you can't if you can't well if you raise
them through raising yeah yeah yeah but
that was a long time ago that was early
80s you know yeah that like the internet
helps so you can see what other people
are doing yeah you know and I've seen
[ __ ] videos of guys that have slowly
fed the damn squirrel uh no squirrels
raccoons to come in the house yeah wild
raccoons he's patting them they're
laying on his lap and [ __ ] yeah because
he's been feeding them they come to her
backyard and like hang out with the
kitties yeah the kitties think they're a
love cats love records I mean whenever a
possum comes they always kind of look at
him like oh that looks like a ugly kitty
yeah they're very but the raccoons
they're kind of like they're very very
monkey like and they like cats and and
cats don't attack raccoons they just
love them our cats are fastened he's
weird yeah every time they see one
outside they're like they run right when
they want to go out there and be like
hey flirting like crazy well it helps
that Beijing is like a big fluffy kind
of creepy tail kind of like a raccoon so
she just probably feels like yeah it's
another one like me she just see just
kind of smell
a little weird that's all yeah so as I
was saying yeah side-missions we knew
you guys love it says we start drinking
I start rolling I guess it's all fun and
games so it's September 7th 1987 there's
a father and son they're out deer
hunting like I said out of season yeah
and yeah in and I'm not sure if I'm
pronouncing this right but the Pisgah
National Forest which is near Asheville
North Carolina and they found a set of
human bones not far from the Stoney
Creek picnic area this body had been
buried in a shallow grave and appeared
to have been later scattered by animals
that means murder if it was buried in a
show yeah now they're not really sure
what the cause of death was because the
body was obviously skeletal it was so
decomposed they figured the the body was
still dressed and there were like um
puncture marks and slashes like in the
bra and it also looked like there were
some minor cut marks on the bone so they
presumed that the person had been
stabbed to death yeah so when they
examined this skeleton they found that
it belonged to a white woman between 40
and 55 years old with extensive dental
work and a severely arthritic knee now
the coroner first kind of estimated that
the woman had been dead for a year but
because it was North Carolina
you know humidity blows it might not
have been that long I'm like I said its
skeletal so it's hard to kind of tell
now it so happened that there was a
doctor in a different city in North
Carolina only about 50 miles from where
the body had been found and he had read
about the body being found in the paper
and he's like you know I remember
getting a flier faxed to me at my
hospital I think he was an emergency
room physician he's like I got a flyer
faxed to me a few months ago about this
missing woman named Judy Smith who
disappeared from Philadelphia so he
contacted the authorities and they
contacted Jeffrey Smith Judy's husband
and she
sent them and he sent them the dental
records at which point they matched the
bones to Judy Smith the dead woman was
Judy Smith found in [ __ ] North
Carolina 600 miles from where she had
last been seen alive somebody picked her
up took her camping and killed her yeah
like I said this is somebody we told her
put her in the trunk and drove out to a
remote area the remotest thing that
[ __ ] could find was a damn
campsite and it says this is a good
place to bury her yeah son like so much
[ __ ] worried about this yeah it's so
[ __ ] weird actually let's um I think
we've been going for probably almost an
hour so let's take a break right now
when we come back to talk about more of
this [ __ ] weird case how this body
ended up here that's like all kind of
crazy [ __ ] theories about this [ __ ]
need me refreshed a screwdriver yes that
would that would be very good so we need
to like request guy vodka some of that
sky I did I I cut from the sky i yeah I
actually like splurged and guts but well
splurged it was only like three three
dollars more than the pinnacle yeah and
then actually I I decided to pay more
because I'm like oh it came with like a
little sample bottle of like citrus sky
vodka I'm like oh nice I can make like
an extra drink out of that so yay I'm
sure you know I'm tactical my liquor
store kind of [ __ ] yeah all right so
we're gonna take a break right now when
we come back we will talk some more
about this mystifying disappearance and
murder of Judy Smith
[Music]
[Music]
you see if she's still doing it hello
baby cookie yeah oh yeah you just always
relaxed and laying on your back in the
middle of the floor like a weirdo yeah
you're such a cutie pie
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're back now before we went
to the break some hunters in North
Carolina I just found some bones and a
shallow grave that ended up belonging to
50 year old Judy Smith who had
disappeared from Philadelphia several
months before who got she been stabbed
uh yeah yeah and as I said the place
where her body was found was 600 miles
from where she had last been seen but
that wasn't the only weird thing now
they also found that the body as I said
it had been scattered a little bit but
it still had like clothes on it weirdly
though the clothes that the body was
wearing were like more suited to like
cold weather hiking clothes like she had
jeans she had long johns and hiking
boots which her family they showed her
family like pictures of those clothes
and she's like yeah those aren't hers or
she bought them somewhere else because
they had never seen them before um you
know and it clearly wasn't what she had
last been seen in when she was in
Philadelphia she had just been wearing
something like you know it was spring in
Philadelphia it was kind of like warm
clothes and she was walking around
sightseeing you know there were also a
bunch of other items found alongside the
body that they didn't think belonged to
her like there was a pair of like really
expensive sunglasses there was a blue
vinyl backpack that had like a bunch of
winter clothing in it now
this was significant because Judy was
well known for carrying a very
distinctive bright red backpack and in
fact if you look up there's pictures of
her like on the internet and there's
even pictures of her wearing it cuz they
said well I mean her kids were like
every time she went on a trip she always
wore that red backpack and they never
did find that however they did find and
and she did have it because some of the
people that said that they saw her like
even in Philadelphia and stuff said yes
she had a bright red backpack on so they
remembered it but they never did find
the backpack in North Carolina this was
a blue one and it had winter clothes in
it
those close theater I don't know they
never really said I don't like I don't
know if she bought them at some point
like after with I don't know it just
seems to me like I think she got another
boyfriend she got a new boyfriend who
wanted to take her camping and hiking
and bought and bought her new stuff
maybe that backpack was worn out by the
time that happened yeah and then one
thing led to another they got into a
fight or he really he realized he didn't
like her and they they got into a fight
he killed her yeah it's a possibility
but yes there's something that if you
saw it happen it would make perfect
sense well all of them are like they're
all but it's like it's just this one it
just seems so odd because she ended up
so far away and it's like it just seemed
weird that she would like set out of her
own volition without you know it's not
that weird to like oh not tell your
husband where you going but the thing is
if you were gonna take off why go to all
the trouble of oh I forgot my driver's
license oh I have to buy a later flight
because I assume she still had to pay
for the first flight even though she
missed it right and then she had to buy
another one like why even bother like
going to Philadelphia and then taking
off like the same day that seems very
weird I can't answer that I wasn't there
that's what I mean so it's to me that
like this whole case is [ __ ] weird I
don't know like what anyone's reasoning
is or nothing
so another thing that they were able to
establish they're like well clearly
robbery was not the motive because even
though like they never found her wallet
her or her ID or anything like that but
the backpack had eighty dollars in cash
in it and there was a shirt that was
buried like near the remains that had
$87 in the front pocket which again
seems weird cuz that's not usually a
place that women put money in the front
pocket of a shirt it seems like this was
something that was not well planned out
yeah wasn't a robbery and the murder
probably wasn't planned she had a bunch
of money stashed on her in certain
places and whoever killed her didn't
realize the
and didn't even think of check that's
what I'm seeing maybe that just I don't
know but you would think if she was
traveling traveling around with a new
boyfriend he probably wouldn't know that
she had that he had that she had money
on her yeah unless maybe he was just so
spooked he was just trying to get her
buried and gone as quickly as possible
yeah and for somebody showed up I mean
it's just weird like I said this was her
money though yeah now like I said I'll
get into that in a minute but it did
kind of like jive with how much cash she
had taken how do they know she was
buried I'd like to see this burial site
well now what okay now from what I've
heard and I don't know if this is
correct or not but from what I've read
like I said I spent eight hours reading
about this shicken find it fascinating
from what I've read this site where this
is found it's like a camp sits a little
bit remote but it's not that far it's
about a quarter of a mile from like a
fairly busy like tourist area but it's
real steep you know I mean it's like
it's kind of a steep trail now there had
been where she was buried
it was like it was like the the hollow
of a tree so there was like a depression
there already but then there was like
dirt put over her and then like some of
her other clothing and stuff was also
buried like separate maybe she was
attacked by a guy stabbed her up so bad
she just really lost a lot of blood
slightly pair of paralyzed and she got
cold she didn't die that she stayed
alive he left her there for dead you
know maybe she regained consciousness
something like that she could move a
little bit but not enough to save
herself so as she got cold of the night
she started to dig herself a little bit
of shelter and then died maybe she
wasn't actually buried maybe she did
that kind of wooded shoulders yeah
there's dug herself a little hole to try
to stay warm but because of loss of
blood maybe you know nerve damage or
whatever maybe she had tendons cut up
from it and I haven't seen the damage on
her body you know man
maybe she couldn't get up and save
herself so she dug herself a little hole
you know as
cold in the night and as you died maybe
it was something like that although I
mean she had been dead since April
probably like you know shortly after she
disappeared from Philadelphia I mean is
it really that cold in North Carolina in
April maybe a night you know I mean I
mean it wouldn't be freezing cold
no not freezing cold but maybe either
blood loss and hurt maybe you try or you
maybe you try to just get yourself a
little bit of shelter maybe it started
raining slightly so and I you know what
you know what's interesting is I was on
the web slits forum and there's like 25
pages of like comments about this case
um and a couple people were like you
know what if well one what if the body
was misidentified maybe that maybe
that's not even her um you know which
kind of opens up a whole new can of room
and it actually opens up to more
mysteries because it's like you know one
where is Judy Smith - who the [ __ ] is
that you know what I mean so I don't
know I'm not going there and like I said
there were some dentists and stuff on
the forum that said you know it's it's
actually pretty easy to identify
somebody even if you just have one tooth
because they're very distinctive so
they're liking a person yeah they're
like operating under the assumptions
this is that this is probably her um I
did see a couple people there like maybe
she wasn't murdered maybe she was killed
by a bear would you know that maybe I
don't know like I would think that they
would be able to tell that but maybe not
you'd have to see the damage on the
bones yeah I mean like blades gonna
leave a certain kind of stretch and a
team of teeth they're gonna believe
something else right maybe it's
misidentified maybe that maybe the the
marks on those bones were postmortem
things gnawing on it and maybe yeah
although like I said I'm pretty sure
that they would maybe was a bad autopsy
or something but yeah I mean there's no
way no I remember not look down like
cash she was definitely camping it does
appear though yeah it does appear that
she went camping a robbery was even the
motive was not robbery she had money on
her and she had her her wedding ring was
on her tail and she was killed by
something and left yeah either a person
or an animal it is an interesting case
but so well there's more
it's like you're just going off like I'm
done I'm not done there was no sign of a
camp being set in that night I know of
it seemed like like I said she had a
backpack whether it was hers or not I
don't know
and it had and she it looked like she
had bought some clothes for hiking
because she had hiking boots and she
ended up and apparently she didn't have
that before um some reports I saw said
that she also had a flashlight and that
she also had a paperback book but I
don't know if that's like I'm only a
couple of sources here's a deal you
don't I mean I mean I'm next infantry if
I was ever gonna be homeless I would
never be a bum you know I mean I get my
gear together and I do with what she's
got to do yeah I just can't for a living
you know and be a mountain man cuz I
could do that yes I could live I could
run trot lines and fish and you know
snare animals you know I were like
snaring but when it comes between life
and death you can air yeah and you know
build my own log cabin you know I'd
rather do that to be a bomb well yeah
you know I mean for sure but maybe she's
doing something like that maybe she was
just camping for a living in these camp
grounds and she was and she ran afoul
with something or someone maybe bear
maybe a man yeah but like I said you
know I'm not sure aside that same thing
maybe she wanted to live in honor I'm
talking about my live at the campgrounds
it just to me it seems weird that I mean
a 50 year old woman um as far as I know
she hadn't been having any problems I
think only one of her friends said oh
the marriage was quote unquote tenuous
they had been together a long time but
they hadn't been married that long it
hadn't even been a year and according to
everyone else including their kids and
all their other friends it's like no
they were totally happy happily married
it was like nothing going on so I don't
know what the reason would be for her to
just take off and it's like like I said
it's not that weird to just like take up
like I need to get away from my husband
or whatever but it's like you would
think that she would at least tell her
kids where she was going she was a nurse
you would at least think that she would
tell a client where she was going I mean
or something if she was taking off on
purpose I mean that seems very strange
and especially like I said after she had
gone through all that rigmarole of
apparently actually going to
Philadelphia even though she'd missed
the first flight and showing up there
and yeah I'm gonna go things like why
just disappear that seems very weird
I've heard law enforcement people say
that I mean people do weird to [ __ ] in
many cases of people even very wealthy
people just having like a mental break
and just say [ __ ] it and they leave yeah
I guess and they start a whole new I
mean people aren't logical all the time
I mean obviously and some people just
like do random [ __ ] running from stress
that they didn't like or a lifestyle
that they didn't like or didn't choose
yeah something that society told them
they had to be bad so they're trying to
do that they didn't like it yeah maybe I
don't know but like I said okay so as I
said so they find the body they found
this you know all the money she had her
wedding ring they never did find her red
backpack as far as I know they never did
find the clothes that she had last been
seen in but she had all these different
clothes on now after they found the body
and after they publicized who it was a
bunch of people in the Asheville North
Carolina area came forward and said that
they had seen her like back in April
which was a few days after she had
vanished from Philadelphia now one of
these people she was like a retail clerk
and she worked and I think it was like a
one of those Christmas store type things
you know like really around we can buy
ornaments at [ __ ] yeah and she said yeah
that woman came in here um she seemed
very friendly she seemed and seemed
under any duress or anything like that
um and she actually said that this woman
said I'm from Boston my husband is a
lawyer and he's attending a conference
in Philadelphia now whether the woman
actually did remember that or if she
just read about Judy Smith and like just
like that and put that in there I don't
know but she's saying that that's what
the woman said because she was talking
to her while she was in this store um
and she said that this woman also said
yeah I just decided to come down here to
Asheville yeah just she didn't really
give a reason she just said she decided
to come down here so there were a couple
of other sightings of her as well in the
Asheville
area so there was a guy that ran a deli
in Asheville and he said yeah a woman
that looked like Judy Smith came in here
and spent $30
she bought a toy truck and a whole bunch
of sandwiches which weird yeah
also there was a woman who worked at the
Biltmore Estate which if you're not from
here is like a really really popular
tourist attraction it's like a big huge
mansion and there's like campgrounds all
around it and restaurants and all kind
of [ __ ] like that now she said that a
woman resembling Judy Smith had driven
up to one of the Biltmore Estate
campgrounds in a gray sedan and asked if
she could park the car there and sleep
in it hmm right
so the woman's like no you can't really
you know park it here sleep in it she
also said that the car was full of like
boxes and bags like I don't know if like
yeah hoarding or if she'd just bought a
bunch of [ __ ] all right nice yeah so she
was like okay well you can't like sleep
in your car here and she was like okay
no prob and then she just drove off
so she identified the car it was a gray
sedan that's all they know but it's like
where did this car come from because
here's one thing that even though she
had that Judy knew they needed that Judy
had some cash with her she had a credit
card I think it was like an American
Express gold card or something like that
at least that her husband knew about and
that wasn't used from the day she
disappeared
so either she had a credit card that
nobody knew about like under a different
name or she had more cash that nobody
knew about or something because she did
have like I said she had a credit card
and her husband knew about it and stuff
but they flagged it and it didn't ever
pretty sure that that's her as far as
they know I mean like I said these are
this should happen okay so um nobody as
far as I know as far as I can determine
nobody that saw her in Asheville North
Carolina saw her with anyone else
because like I said it does seem like
maybe she met somewhat like maybe she
had a pen pal or maybe she met a boy
friend or boyfriend lived down there or
something like that and she was going to
like hang out with him but nobody
reported ever seeing her with anybody
she was always alone so again a little
weird now another thing that was kind of
weird is like as far as anybody that
knew her could remember she had never
particularly expressed a desire to go to
North Carolina before um or go hiking
there she was kind of an outdoorsy kind
of woman she did like some kind of minor
hiking and [ __ ] like that like you know
around where she was in Massachusetts
and [ __ ] where she was from but she had
never like specifically said oh I want
to go to the Biltmore Estate or I want
to go to North Carolina in fact all they
know that she went to the state of North
Carolina at one point before because her
husband Jeffrey who I said he's actually
like morbidly obese he's passed away now
but um he was at a weight-loss clinic
there in Raleigh Durham for a week and
she like went down there to visit him
but Raleigh Durham is like 250 miles
from where her body was found so it's
not like she was just like oh I'm down
here for a week like visiting my husband
at the weight loss clinic and I met some
dude right here and now I'm come to us
cuz you know what I mean it was like far
away and as far as I know that was a
couple years prior and that was the only
time that she had ever been there as far
as I could determine so so they're
asking Jeffery Smith and like I said the
husband has been pretty much I mean
obviously you know they couldn't arrest
him on it because they didn't have
enough like you know evidence but
they're keeping him as a person of
interest this whole time and I think a
lot of cops kind of thought that maybe
he was involved um boy it didn't sound
like him yeah that's what I'm saying I
think it's very very unlikely and like I
said he passed away I believe in 2005 I
think from weight related issues cuz
like I said he was he was very very
overweight um maybe that contributed to
you know yeah I'm kind of marital
unhappiness oh [ __ ] that's kind of
overweight ooh and you know what okay
and I don't mean to like I don't mean to
be mean
it does seem like when they put like the
missing-persons reports out about her
the description of her said that she was
five foot one and that she was 135
pounds now I'm looking at the picture of
her going go know what that is not a
hundred and thirty five pounds five foot
one I look I'm five foot three I weigh
more than that and she looks way bigger
than me so I'm just saying I don't know
if she just carries her weight
differently because some people do but I
to me it looks more like 160 hundred
seventy pounds tell me Jenny man so far
this sounds like the story of a woman
who maybe had some kind of a mental you
know I mean I don't want to say mental
issue but maybe some people didn't just
they just can't take it in email it out
she kind of glitched out she says [ __ ]
it I'm gonna get away from [ __ ] for a
while and she had her she had her own
money and she bought a cheap card [ __ ]
went camp and then you know had fun for
a while tried to leave the past in the
past and by chance I think Croft passed
with something that killed her
I'm not convinced as a man yet it may
have been an animal that's what I mean
yeah I'm not entirely sure but yeah I'd
have to see them I have to see that damn
I have to see those bones yes you know
they said they're cut marks on those
bones yeah you should you know I want I
want to see photos like I said it looked
like there were stab marks through like
the bra and like it looked like slashes
and like punctures from something metal
like a blade we're not talking my that's
here is that like I said as far as I
know like everything that they could
determine was the coroner ruled that it
was he's like I'm not gonna say like for
certain but he's like it looks like she
was dead I mean it's very rare but there
have been people who have been biking
killed by mountain lions yeah and you
know an American mountain lion is not
known as being particularly deadly or
aggressive but there are individuals out
there that will run down somebody on a
bicycle and kill him yeah
have to kind of compare you know what
what does what does the clothing will
look like after an attack like that you
know I mean maybe this wasn't man you
know but I have seen the photographs
again of the of the evidence it's weird
so yeah it's still plausible she was
trying to get away from it she was
basically taking a break yeah yeah I
mean so well is she's in a guy killed
her or uh you know a guy she didn't know
killed her or an animal killed or
something like that
now one of the reasons why the
authorities kind of clung to the idea
that her husband had something to do
with it now he said that as far as he
knew that Judy had taken $200 in cash
with her on the day that she went
sightseeing in Philadelphia and that she
also had her American Express gold card
there was also $500 in cash that was
left back at the hotel room so she left
$500 well that was like I guess that was
there like walking around money or
whatever but it was apparently that was
still $500 left in the room okay so okay
yeah now like I said there were also
okay now Jeffrey Smith he was a lawyer
like I said he refused to take a
polygraph test now he said he told the
police that he would take a polygraph
test
if the FBI administered it okay however
because the FBI would not get involved
on the case for whatever reason because
it didn't didn't meet their criteria or
whatever that almost makes sense he
didn't want to be set up that's what I'm
saying so I they acted like that made
him like super suspicious but I'm like
one look he's a lawyer um he knows his
[ __ ] like he knows his rights and
everything like that so I can't really
say I blame him and honestly lie
detector test it's like you know they
make a big deal it's like they don't
they don't let you like put them into
evidence at a trial for a reason because
they can be manipulated
yeah there's training programs to teach
you how to beat them exactly so they're
not super and then the thing is it's
like so he's so the cops are
kind of saying oh well he refused a
polygraph test he's like no I said I
would take one at the FBI administered
it the FBI said well we're not gonna
really gonna get involved because this
case isn't like doesn't meet our
criteria so he's like yeah no thank you
and then when they asked him to do one
later he's like okay well I would but by
that point he was on this like weird
heart medication and he was afraid that
it would give like a false positive so
he didn't want to do it then like I said
in that primer I think that's pretty
reasonable I mean like I said they make
a big deal about polygraph tests all
they use them for I mean at least in my
experience is eliminating a suspect I
mean that's pretty much all they used
them for but they made a big deal about
oh he didn't want to take one you know
what I mean now there was another thing
too that the police thought was a little
strange now they said when they searched
like and this is going back to April
like you know a day or two after Judy
had disappeared so they searched the
hotel room now Judy's luggage was there
because as I said presumably and had
gone on the plane with her husband like
even though she had had to take a later
flight now they said that her luggage
was there and it had clothes in it but
the clothes hadn't been worn now
Geoffrey had said remember that when he
woke up on the day like after she got
there that night and said she was in the
shower
so they're like wool did she just put
the same clothes back on that she had
flown in cuz that seems a little weird
and he's like yeah that's what she did
she put the same clothes back on because
none of the clothes that she brought in
her luggage were worn so they thought
that was a little weird that she just
like also they thought it was weird that
there were no like FEMA there were no
cosmetics or like you know female type
toiletry items in the room but when they
asked her kids about it they said you
know she wasn't like super super girly
they're like she did have like some
lotion and some basic cosmetics and
stuff but they're like they she usually
kept him in a red backpack which she
would have had with her so maybe she had
a change of clothes in the backpack as
well I don't really know
I'm just saying that the cops thought
that was weird that none of her clothing
had been worn and that kind of like some
investigators were like well maybe she
didn't even come to Philadelphia and the
husband had killed her beforehand
and then set this whole thing up to make
it look like oh I forgot my driver's
license and then you know just to get an
alibi but that seems a little convoluted
to me
well they they identified that body out
there and that damn campground didn't
they yeah as long as that happened then
think about this
they found her out I can't grow with a
new pack and a blue clothes and a bunch
of clothes they were suited for camping
and hiking yeah
that means she wasn't out there against
her will nope yeah she went on her own
yeah she went on her own the car wasn't
there was it not that I know of no I
don't know if they ever found the car
maybe she was killed for that car yeah
like because the car was never found
like some people were presuming that her
killer had driven her to the lake she
was with that person and then like after
he killed her he took off in and maybe
she went camping and ran into some
people and they killed her and took her
car yeah it could be and then they had
two cars after that yeah you know
something like I mean the thing is like
I said yeah it's just barely possible
that like her husband might have hired
somebody to do it but they said okay
well there's no way one there's no way
he could have done it because firstly he
was at the conference for those three
days it's like everybody saw him he even
moderated like one of the panels you
know so he was there yeah um secondly
like I said he was morbidly obese the
place where her body was found it was
about a quarter mile of really really
steep trail there like there is no way
that he could have carried a body up
that way or even walked up that way
without a body because he was just in
really really really bad shape and it's
like you know what I mean if he wanted
to kill his wife it seemed like there
would have been like no simpler ways to
do it so I would say you can eliminate
him yeah I really don't think that he
had anything to do with it at all
and like
I said you know not only all of that but
he also spent like thousands and
thousands of dollars of his own money
like looking for her after she
disappeared he seemed genuinely
concerned about where she had gone you
know he hired private investigators he
just you know what I mean I just don't
think there was a very hard this whole
case is that she was up there camping
with camping equipment the car wasn't
there that's really what this case is
all about she wasn't there against her
will however she got she got there
somehow yeah
it's believed that she had her own car
well where's that damn car yeah that's
what I'd like to know and like if she
rented it where's that we're like
where's the record yeah I mean I the car
I think she bought a used car maybe she
did but for our foreign fans I mean you
can't rent a car without a credit card
even today you ready clever yeah and
another thing is is that it's very rare
to be killed for a car in the United
States because in the American culture
and an American economy a car really
isn't worth killing somebody the poorest
of people in the United States have a
[ __ ] car in some Paulo Brazil yeah
they'll kill you [ __ ] for a car
during a carjacking even even a stupid
car not so much in the United States are
just not worth enough to kill well you
can buy a cheap one off the graceless is
really nothing yeah yeah you can cheat
buy a cheap car for nothing and the
parts aren't really worth a whole lot
and then if you steal something that's
expensive like a Ferrari you can't go
anywhere with it I mean it just sticks
out like a sore thumb
yeah and I've heard that there are
high-end car thieves that steal Bugattis
and Ferraris but those are very
organized car thieves they have whole
ways of getting that car out of country
and they usually end up somewhere and
like Saudi Arabia that's where they're
sending them they'll some to some Saudi
prince for a [ __ ] for a song you know
I mean but you can't sell a Ferrari here
on the black market
there's just it costs too much attention
the cops would know well yeah you have
to get might as well
the big neon things stolen yeah if you
steal something expensive you have to
get it out of the country and that's
definitely not happening here she wasn't
killed for that car not on the normal
means I think maybe they killed her and
used the cars and means to get out well
yeah they just took it they just took it
to get out of there but they didn't walk
that car that wasn't the motive yeah
it's just like I said okay so um yeah so
as I was saying her kids also said that
she that they had seen their mother
alive the night before they left for
Philadelphia and her ticket on the later
flight to Philadelphia the 7:30 flight
had been used so there was the correct
amount of passengers on the plane and I
think there was at least one or two
other witnesses on the plane who said
they had seen a woman that resembled
Judy Smith on that flight so you know
like I said I was reading through like
this 28 pages of [ __ ] theories about
people and people like I don't even
think she even went to Philadelphia I
think her husband had her killed like
before they went and he just set up this
whole thing and I'm like yeah but that's
very different is it yeah and I said
that just seems super too much trouble
of like I said if you want your wife
dead there's way easier ways to do it
away with it yeah it just seems like way
too much trouble like to go through like
oh she's gonna set up Tussauds Oh why'd
she forget her driver's license she
traveled all the time you'd think that
she would know it's like [ __ ] man I've
forgotten my driver's license a couple
times too like though I'm like this
woman I'm gonna put this woman in the
category of the runaway bride yeah for
one reason or another she ran from her
husband mental issues something like
that maybe she had a secret boyfriend
maybe he act maybe they went camping
together and he killed her might have
been something like that yeah I'm kind
of feeling like um I mean it was 1997
you know internet dating wasn't really a
big thing and her family said that she
wasn't super computer savvy I don't
think she had a computer or anything
like that but it's possible that she
could have met someone I think it's
nothing happened like they're like she
was like a pen pal or she just nobody
that had moved away or you
or something like that she left her her
she left her husband she stayed in
hotels for a while while she was in the
hotel she met an interesting guy yeah
and then he was kind of in a similar
situation where he was just kind of like
a nomad traveled around he's like let's
be campers let's go camping for a couple
years and then they go do their camping
for a couple years maybe there were some
other people with them you know yeah it
wasn't one it wasn't maybe it was two
guys one of them she was you know one of
them she was having a relationship with
the other one maybe not so much yeah I
mean so they all go camping and for some
reason another fight breaks out or a
disagreement they he kills her and then
both those dudes drives the car out of
there drive the cars out of there you
know I mean yeah in a ditch her car
maybe [ __ ] pull push it off on a
cliff there are places in the United
States where you can ditch a cardinal
never be found yeah yeah I mean like I
said it from all evidence it does appear
that she went to that place by her own
voluntarily there like it didn't look
like the body had been dragged there it
didn't look like I mean she looked like
she was dressed for hiking yeah it's you
dressed for a long trip there to stay
there so she she willingly went there
yeah it's like the question is like why
did she meet somebody or just politic
did she just decide like follow some
reason like hey I want to go camping I
must say I must say knowing the nature
of a woman and you ought you you should
say this you'd probably believe this too
she probably didn't go on her own there
was somebody else that said let's go do
this I think there's a lot more long
yeah because it really seems I mean I'm
not saying it's impossible obviously but
it really does seem strange to just go
through all this rigmarole and you're
going on this big trip with your husband
and you have all these plans and stuff
and then all of a sudden oh I'm gonna
blow up my whole entire life and vanish
and not even tell my [ __ ] kids where
I'm going and just so I can go all the
way down to [ __ ] North Carolina 600
miles away and go hiking at this [ __ ]
place that I've never even been to
before it just seems like well I mean I
could see dreams I think you
if there was a medical condition
involved what if she had a [ __ ] brain
tumor the seeds that's kind of like
because I'm kind of of the mind it's
like yeah there were like all those
sightings of her that day in
Philadelphia and some of them were
probably not her some of them were
probably the homeless woman but what
about the the woman that they said
stayed at that Hotel it's like a
homeless woman wouldn't have money to
stay at a hotel so maybe she had like a
psychotic break man like maybe she had a
stroke or something had a stroke had a
brain tumor and then all of a sudden she
runs from her husband meets another guy
she's very quiet because she has this
because she has like a yeah and then
they go camping and then she starts
acting crazy because of her brain tumor
a fight break study dude kills her
leaves are there and they take her car
and his car they split or something like
that
now might have been soft you know yeah
like I said I get like every every
scenario that I can think of is weird
yeah you know what I mean it's just it's
every single scenario is weird
now here's another complicating factor
there was a serial killer named Gary
Michael Hilton now in 2007 which was a
decade after this incident he murdered
an elderly couple in the same National
Forest in North Carolina and he also was
later convicted of killing and beheading
two other hikers in one in Georgia and
one in Florida they were younger women
like so he would kind of like go in
these national forests that was kind of
his thing and he would attack people at
random and behead them sometimes and
sometimes tied them to trees and stabbed
them to death so even though the Judy
Smith murder happened like ten years
before his first known crimes because he
did get convicted of that show later on
the modus operandi is similar enough
that you know they're kind of wondering
maybe this was like an era maybe he'd
been doing it for a really long time and
we
just never caught him maybe this was
like an early maybe she just went out
like camping by herself and then this
[ __ ] happened upon her yeah and
you know because that seems I you know
it's like where's her car though maybe
he took it
where's his maybe he didn't have one
yeah maybe he just like wandered around
and like looking for people because like
I said the one that he did in 2007 which
was in the exact same National Forest as
where she was found you know they were
they were older I mean they were seven
like that they were like camping out in
the herb like an in a Winnebago or
something and he's just like approached
him you know anything lis anything's
possible but I'm gonna say it's gonna
lean more towards whoever killed her was
the person that took her out there
that's what I'm saying yeah I kind of
feel like likely like I said from all
the evidence presented it doesn't seem
like anybody kidnapped her from
Philadelphia because one well and
another thing too that her family said
like like I said she was seen in
Philadelphia and she was like doing
normal touristy [ __ ] but then like some
people SAR and she was like doing like
crazy [ __ ] but her family all said one
thing about her was that she was very
loud and she would like tout like
whatever she wanted she would [ __ ]
tell you they're like if somebody tried
to like snatch her off the street she
would make a huge [ __ ] scene what if
instead of it's a serial killer it was a
one-off type of deal dude took her out
there and she attacked him and he killed
her in self-defense
she had that damn brain problem yeah
yeah I guess that's a possibility she
started freaking out and did something
and he [ __ ] popped her and then he's
trying to fighting and the guy started
to escalate and then it's like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] I'm through with you I'll stab her
yeah and he's like oh [ __ ] some people
have speculate that crazy [ __ ] leaves
are out there in front splits some
people have kind of made a big deal too
about and I'm not sure how far away it
was but it's fun it gives a couple
articles I read
that oh not that far away from where the
body was found was a quote-unquote
lesbian house so I guess it was just out
yeah was a house where a lesbian couple
lives is gonna come out and killua's
bein happy so something like that she
laid a map to its red marks right on the
map it's a house it's a house of two
women so some have speculated that maybe
she wasn't running away to meet a man
maybe she was running away to meet
another woman like maybe she was the
secret lesbian that's why she had that
break living a life you know yeah I
don't know it's like you know it's out
there yeah so I'm not saying that it was
necessarily a woman that killed her but
maybe she went out there you know with
the purpose of like meeting this woman
that she knew or something like that and
then somebody else killed her or you
know it could have been something that
meant so the case is is she's fed out
there she went out there on her own by
her own volition she that's they do
think though she bared she was prepared
and everybody that saw her in Asheville
said she was acting normal and the car's
gone yeah that's that's you know that's
weird where the [ __ ] is that car car and
like I said some people too like some
people went off on some crazy tangents
and stuff but some people have said well
maybe maybe the body wasn't her but I
said but that just like I said that just
brings up two more mysteries right yeah
because like well who the [ __ ] is it and
where the [ __ ] is she you know what I
mean it's like yeah it's it's easy for
somebody to get murdered and they'd
never find them make it happens all the
time but maybe she stole if that wasn't
her like maybe she's still alive
somewhere yeah but this [ __ ] was on like
[ __ ] unsolved mysteries I don't know
when but they have like um her husband
passed away in 2005 I think okay um but
he put up a bunch of money and like the
cops put up a bunch of money I think
there's like a seventeen thousand dollar
reward or something like that but this
like I like I said I spent [ __ ] ages
and ages like reading about this case
it's like fascinated because I don't
know it just seems so strange to me that
somebody
this whole sequence events just seems so
improbable well it was over 20 years ago
the guy who did is Friday and some
people have said too because okay check
out the whole like the whole [ __ ] at the
beginning where you know they're going
to the airport and she's like oh I
forgot my driver's license I have to go
back home and take a later flight some
people are saying maybe she did that on
purpose because she was going back home
to get some secret [ __ ] that her husband
didn't know about so she never planned
to go I mean she did go to Philadelphia
apparently because a lot of people saw
her there but maybe she had to go back
and get some [ __ ] that she didn't want
him to know about like stuff that so
maybe she was planning this the whole
time and that was like a ruse so she
could go back and get like extra cash or
a different credit card or something or
like different clothes I think it's best
not to read into it too much yeah but it
does seem like kind of weird that that
happened you know what I mean
because if you were planning on if you
were planning on running away it seems
like why why waste all that time and
money like planning this trip paying for
a flight that you miss and then having
to buy another flight to go later and
then actually going there and saying
you're gonna do this that in the other
and then oh well no really I'm out it's
like what that's very weird I think most
of the testimony witness testimony
agrees that she wasn't in her right mind
if that was even it must have been if
that it was even her but but the
opposite has been all husband without
any warned all the people in Asheville
North Carolina that supposedly saw her
said she was acting normal nobody in
Asheville said she was acting weird I
mean other than saying hey can I sleep
in my car that's a little bit weird but
I mean not that weird not like
masturbating in front of a window weird
yeah and then we're not sure that's her
we're not sure that's her like I said I
mean yeah there was that homeless woman
that looked like her but like I said a
homeless woman wouldn't necessarily have
the money to stay in a hotel for two
days
I don't know Jenni you got me on this
one I mean you know it's kind of I told
you it's [ __ ] weird right yeah
there's not
not not a lot of detail to this case and
I don't know that's why I was like oh
geez I've been drinking I can't figure
this one out that's why I was like
fascinated but because I'm like I'm
reading all these peoples different
theories and stuff I'm like this is the
crazy [ __ ] ever it's like why what
happened like what why would you just
like suddenly decide I mean to me it's
like weirder like if she had just been
out like in Philadelphia oh I'm
sightseeing and some jackass like
[ __ ] hit her over the head and like
kidnapped her and like for whatever
reason like took her to [ __ ] North
Carolina to kill her like let's go 600
miles on a road trip like whatever but
the fact that she went to Philadelphia
like planned the trip and everything
like that and then decided I'm going to
leave and go camping and go camping in
North Carolina without telling anyone
even her children who I mean they were
grown but there were still her kids it's
like without telling anyone where she
was going and then she ends up murdered
that's like what the [ __ ] had what the
[ __ ] happened it's like it's like I
would love to know the [ __ ] sequence
of events there because this is just
mystifying to me mystify there was a man
involved and she's like walking around
in stores like oh yeah I'm from Boston
and my husband's a lawyer she's like she
wasn't hiding it and another thing too
like I said they flagged like her credit
cards and none of them were used so
either she had yes she either had a
bunch of secret cash I mean he knew that
she had $200 like when she went out
sightseeing maybe somebody else was
paying her way either someone else was
paying or she had some like secret [ __ ]
like she had like a bunch of cash that
he didn't know about or she had like
some credit cards she didn't know about
now she had been married two times
before so maybe she had credit cards
like in her old married names yeah or
something like that that he didn't know
about I mean they've been together a
long time but it's not that hard to like
keep him even if she had like a p.o box
why would she like the bills would come
there but it seems like what like why go
to all that trouble why would she have
like the mental wherewithal to say I'm
not going to use
normal credit card I'm he's my other
character that's what I you mean it's
like it's just crazy and now like it
sounds like it's more likely that
whoever she was with was using their
credit card that's right maybe somebody
just bought her a bunch of [ __ ] yeah
like somebody bought her like weird her
red backpack oh did they then I went out
might have been a secret boyfriend and I
think it was worn out so she got a new
one yeah cuz her kid said that will
she'd had that all shot got a new one
and then and a new stock closed to go
camping go hiking you know this could
have been but she either had a secret
man or a secret woman she might have had
a damn girlfriend yeah like I said
that's I think the only reason people
say that that was just because of the
quote unquote lesbian house that was not
like come on it's like a proof of it but
maybe we're assuming it's a man yeah it
didn't necessarily have to be yeah maybe
she had a girlfriend yeah and she kept a
secret from everybody yeah and you maybe
they had too much to drink got into a
fight and [ __ ] girlfriend stabbed her
yeah it does happen
I mean it's some like that I mean
statistically it's much more likely that
it was a man but I mean because I mean
look there lay man maybe baby yeah
you're looking for a man but you're
blinding yourself it might have been she
might have seen her girlfriend yeah I
mean like I said that is something that
some people have thrown around maybe she
planned on coming back yeah you know I
mean what's with a cockamamie story of I
you know I you know I got kidnapped you
know or I had to do this in it there's
been some weird [ __ ] cases true you
know these kind of cases always mystify
me like these people cuz I've written
about a couple cases where like you know
like a woman would like leave her house
and it seemed like super normal and then
like three days later they'd find her
car like abandoned and the airport
parking lot or something like that and
then they never find a find her and it's
like what the like how do you even do
that
I don't it's for many cops it's so weird
to me it's meeting cops on a lot of good
programs say that know there are people
that disappear they just yeah they do on
purpose though rich people will walk
away from an empire you never see him
again
it just seems like
seems like it would take so much
planning yeah I mean because you would
need to have I mean like I said in this
case she would have had to have other
cash stowed away like she she had been
planning it for a long time maybe she
would have had to have other credit
cards that he didn't know about or
something because they didn't I mean the
cops didn't know like any other credit
cards to flag they just knew that you
know that gold card that she had and
that wasn't used by anyone so it's just
mystifying and like I said it's not like
she you know the people that saw her in
Asheville nobody saw her with anybody
nobody said that she was acting weird or
acting like she was like under duress or
threatened by anybody if she was just
shopping like a normal person
it's a mystery that's what I mean that's
why you think that's why it's in you
newb I told you that [ __ ] is [ __ ]
weird that's weird that's why it's in
your third book if you know if you guys
want more mysteries like this and this
is gonna be my [ __ ] plug in the [ __ ]
out of it but that's that's how I got
interested in this is book number three
there's just more mysteries this this
weirds me out of as much as that Roland
tion [ __ ] yeah the horror in room 10 at
10:35 many shows in the past
yeah I've been drinking too heavily to
try to remember these old shows about
Roland I can kind of remember who it was
yeah and happened like in the 30s Oh
like yeah I got choked out I think Danny
well he was like tortured tortured yeah
and stabbed I think there was some gay
action going on with that maybe but it's
like it's just the whole thing that was
weird to me not so much that he got
murdered but that nobody saw anybody
going in or out and like just the whole
way like he was behaving like in the
days before that like he was behaving
like super like he would sit in the room
like with the curtains closed and like
he would just sit there and like watch
the maid do stuff but it's like it was
like super creepy the phone kept getting
yeah off the hook and [ __ ] like that
it's just like a weird [ __ ] case
you've got anything else to add on this
case no that's pretty much it seven
seventeen thousand dollar reward if
anybody knows what happened to this
[ __ ] woman I would love to hear it
because I am just
funneled by this entire case and I have
spent the last couple days reading
everything about this case it could be
it could be that we're missing certain
certain pieces to this puzzle maybe the
[ __ ] law enforcement says yeah
there's some other details that we have
a release to the public way yes
maybe well there's like its problem
maybe there's see it we don't know about
yet so because it doesn't seem to be
enough there to solve this yeah and I
mean I wish someone would because it's
so frustrating to me and you know I
write about unsolved murders all the
time so it's kind of like constantly
frustrating but it's like this is one
that I really want to see solved because
I want to know what the [ __ ] happened
like what the [ __ ] happened this last
cut was like before she live with like
what the [ __ ] was going on it was
something kind of mundane just just that
what's left behind is hard to decipher
you know long but that's why this [ __ ]
is fascinating to people because it's
like you weren't there you didn't see
what happened and what is left happened
like what is left over the evidence
looks like super weird and you can't
think of anything like because I would
never well and I don't have the money
either but it's like I would never just
like hey let's go on a trip and then
like the next day I'm like Boop I'm out
I'm just gonna go six hundred [ __ ]
miles and not like there's something up
with the heart you know my people were
involved okay
influences we're involved you know I
mean maybe I mean I understand no we're
not gonna do or not don't do that come
on come with me something like that or
mental problems yeah it's like if some
of those sightings in Philadelphia were
of her maybe like maybe she had like
what a mini stroke or something really
bad she had some kind of a she wasn't in
her right mind or something that would
actually be that's terrible but it would
actually make me feel better because it
was like give me a reason like why did
you do this why she suddenly started
acting in such a weird way and like just
like I said just blow up your whole life
and not tell anybody where you were
going that just seems very weird to me
yeah yeah alright so you you're getting
all drunk and stuff no I are getting
drunk a bedroom it's getting antsy and
getting Nancy's time me to walk around
okay so we have to light a [ __ ] a [ __ ]
[ __ ] down okay you know [ __ ] a
hostile I love this [ __ ] man we got
other shows you gotta do we could do
this [ __ ] tomorrow yeah we have to
probably yeah we probably I was gonna
record another one tonight but I don't
think I don't think you're in any shape
[Laughter]
it's still fairly early so you can you
know what we haven't done a paranormal
one in a while we gotta do a paranormal
Orson somebody like somebody wanted us
to do superstition mountains like all
the legends and stuff around
superstition mountains so we might yeah
next week or the week after man I've
been fun finding out more and more about
that damn tick-tack UFO yeah yeah that's
what have you found out about it that
that [ __ ] was real just listen to the
effort to the to the guys that saw you
know pilots and the people that worked
we're on those aircraft carriers the
guys are running the radar and guys that
saw a more clearer image of the damn
craft than what was available to the
public it was shaped like a tic-tac and
they had two little things coming out
like little elves coming off the bottom
up he said he saw him clearly almost
kind of like it was a little antennas
come on I like Auto feet he said it's
almost like little exhaust pipes coming
out of the bottom of it but it wasn't
emitting any of any kind of infrared
energy so there wasn't any heat coming
from so you're not talking about
something that's you know jet propulsion
or rocket propulsion it was an unknown
propulsion and the [ __ ] was
outperforming those second Hornets does
every 18 says thing was [ __ ] doing so
Travis yeah yeah man unless there's some
kind of an exotic propulsion out there
that they don't that they don't let us
know about why don't they share that
[ __ ] with the rest of the class they
thought the guys that were [ __ ]
seeing it on radar and then when they
went out there and investigated it they
were thinking man this has got to be
some kind of process some kind of drones
they're in the the pattern of movements
they were using was real kind of random
and like inefficient they were seeing
little white things down by the ocean
jumping around you know they would drop
out and they saw it over a period of
several you know days because they were
doing a field problem out there in the
ocean
Air Force or the Navy was so they
weren't out there wasn't one sighting it
was a bunch of activity that they were
picking up on radar over four days and
then when they finally went out there to
see it
yeah they visually made contact with
this [ __ ] and it was just and it was
about the size of a jet fighter you know
and it was just a damn sheep like a pill
or a tic-tac you know with a couple
little antennas come out of the bottom
of little feet come on bottom of it
and it was you know doing amazing
acrobatics and there were several of
them and I'm just you know and that
evidently changed a bunch of Air Force
pilot or two but a bunch of military
policy about reporting them they're like
yeah go ahead and report they want to
know about it and they have camera
footage you know because the trackers
were locking on to it so they know what
they look like they showed some of the
stuff to the public but one of the one
of the crewmen said that the that the
version that they had that the
government took from them has a lot
higher resolution that you could really
see it really well what it was and they
don't know what it was now Trump made a
comment on that he said that he saw but
he wasn't convinced he's you know the
new UFO stuff they asked him that said
you know what's up with this new UFO
[ __ ] and he's like yeah yeah yeah you
know I'm not convinced but you know
we'll just go ahead and take the reports
so you know like I said if it's UFOs I
wish they would like just pop in and go
hey guys it's us and we have all this
that and the other thing help us out
aliens some badass propulsion you know
we need help just you know help ya know
they're not gonna help they don't have
anything to do with us they were doing
something on the bottom of the ocean if
what these guys they were [ __ ] around
on the ocean they weren't here for us
they were looking at something else and
I think he's gotta imagine
you guys ain't [ __ ] yeah you're right
they're looking at the earth they're
gonna take over that they're gonna take
over I think of Zi I don't think there
were any beings in it I think there were
robots doing it artificial intelligence
that you're talking about the size of
jet fighter okay so they're big tick
down yeah yeah yeah sure there could be
aliens in there it could be there's a
bunch of them and they were moving
around crazy and and then they would one
of them evidently according to went into
the water just POW hit the water kept on
going huh
it didn't evidently slowed down they got
they did get a reading off of it is
slowed down a bit but it didn't seem to
the transition from being in the air and
going into the water didn't really
wasn't traumatic before it so you're not
talking about a normal craft and you're
talking about something's kind of
bending with the laws of physics you
know they had to have it you know I saw
the fish I saw some of the footage it is
evidently not the good footage
cuz that got taken away they took the oh
yeah that it's not it's still kind of
class like yeah you can just watch that
good the Schulich steepy yeah it's the
shitty looks just what they let you see
jerks but yeah something's happening
we'll see ya like I said I'd be excited
if like little extra shirt
extraterrestrials do you say extra
testicles extra testicles I wish I said
that okay all right yeah alien testicles
yeah and that's what we need extra
testicles it's not - there's three oh
well wait okay if it's extra testicle -
well there have to be two extra ones
okay there's not - there's do you live
yeah that works too
okay so they come down and like a little
contingent a little testicle trying to
make sense out of somebody that just
doesn't make sense okay I'm not making
sense right now
yeah clearly no I'm having a good time
like just picturing these little alien
testicles like coming down from from a
distance dog yeah
the testicular alien yeah maybe we want
make me want to watch it Close
Encounters of the Third Kind now well we
can watch it if you want to I don't have
it that's right well it might be on it
might be on Netflix or I fall asleep at
times done I probably would too I don't
mean to be honest with you
what hungry yeah wait till tomorrow you
don't shut down Jenny all right I'm
shutting it down
now it's because Tom will yell at me I'm
not allowed to do my little see I don't
know anymore
no you can get him dude I'm just saying
you can do it if you want to support the
show just go to our patreon page yeah go
to copy go to patreon and clock podcast
you'll notice or also we have a PayPal
yeah if you want to get a paper soft
face book yeah look us up on Facebook
just education money you can pay us in
money you can pass in taffy you can pass
the pass got something got a goth dude
on the border of Mexico there he's gonna
[ __ ] send us a bottle of tequila all
kinds of it's all good all kind of candy
booze yeah whatever is all Jenni's book
will be out any kind of food book will
be out in a few weeks
yeah I know I'm working very hard only
two more chapters you say it's gonna
kick it and it's like most of the
audiobook is done too but it's like I
still have to do like five chapters of
them got to [ __ ] down to the science now
so we're the [ __ ] the the print book
the e-book and the audio book will be
out within days of each other yeah like
the print and ebook has to go first
because the audiobook thing you have to
already have had a published print book
that it's based off of you know what I
mean and then when you upload the audio
like it usually takes like a like 10
days sometimes two weeks for them to
like do the quality control and [ __ ]
like that yeah they gotta check it but
you know it's it's pretty much it's
almost all done this is done with a new
microphone and a new amp so it's good
yeah it sounds much better than the
other ones even though I did redo the
other ones with you with this lady yeah
what they
but the the new one I'm will be within
brand this is like my real new super
expensive like that's like yeah it's
gonna be a good one you know and then
she's gonna reboot all her fiction yeah
that'll be a one-stop my next project
where you buy it and it'll be a big
print book it'll have every all her
fiction she's ever done yeah I'm doing
several volumes of like yeah it's gonna
be cool you know then we unite the
bodies a little I'm consolidating the
holes and unpublished short stories and
all that guy stuff you know and I'm
gonna do audio versions because I've
never done audio book versions of any of
my fiction yeah same thing Stephen King
did with like his work with like
monkeyshines and you know all the little
short stories yeah it's not called that
though it's like let's go somebody told
me and I keep forgetting I thought it's
called monkey shot no you're just
thinking that because it's got like the
monkey with the symbols like was it
front like on the artwork but it's not
called that
it's called [ __ ] somebody told me and
then I forgot again that was called
monkey [ __ ] no it's not that was a movie
though was that was a horror movie that
came out in the late 80s early 90s it
was about like a paraplegic and he had a
helper monkey
which I wish I had I helped him lucky
but yeah he had a helper monkey that um
would get all his [ __ ] for him oh good
because he couldn't move his arms or
legs and of course it all went terribly
terribly wrong and evil and whatnot
because it's a horror movie okay but
yeah so I think it was early 90s maybe
monkeyshines it wasn't bad but I can't
reward the [ __ ] book no it's not it's
just I just camera on the front with the
symbols okay which is funny because it
was that [ __ ] that movie that was on
Mystery Science Theater Merlin shop of
mystical wonders yeah and that was that
whole there was like a whole like
through line of the whole [ __ ]
because it had like a bunch of stories
in it and it had one of those monkeys
it's a symbol and he was like evil and
he was like mcil never looked every time
he put the symbols together like people
with - good that was a good collection
man I had the mist on it it had survivor
type yeah yeah it had a bunch of good
stuff yeah there was a lot of good
stories then I have it somewhere it's
like it's up in the closet probably
that's what like we're on my paper back
so probably you could look for it if you
wanted to if you really wanna know what
the title was because I totally blanked
out again look I totally blanked on it
again and somebody like cuz we talked
about it before and somebody in the
comments said oh no it's called this and
I was like yeah that's right yeah I had
forgotten all about it and then I forgot
again everybody knows it is monkeyshines
and there's nothing all right so
hopefully you guys have enjoyed episode
154 about this very weird disappearance
and murder case also on unsolved
mysteries you want to look that [ __ ] up
it was quite a few years ago we will see
you next time bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]